Here are the answers that I got. The length method returns the number of
individual characters in the string. There were 7. The substring method
extracts a substring that sits inside the bigger string. In our case, it
extracted this string. Whenever you want to extract substrings, you have to
understand how the positions in a string are numbered. In Java the initial
position is 0, that may sound strange but it's actually pretty useful, and then
it goes from there. The string has length 7 and the position's in it are 0, 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6. That's 7 position's. Now in the substring here you see this 3
here. That is the position of the first character that we want to include in
the substring. The seven here is the first position that we don't want to have
anymore. We don't want position seven. In fact, there is no position seven. We
want the ones from three to six. That sounds a bit odd to most people when they
see it the first time. But there is an advantage. When you subtract these two
numbers, 7 minus 3, that's 4, and that's the length of the substring that
you're extracting. The next method here, the indexOf method finds the position
of a given character. So, over here I want to know where does the C occur for
the first time. And it will go through and say, that's at position three. And
finally, you already seen this plus operator in lesson two. It takes two
strings and glues them together or as we like to say in programming is, it
concatenates them. So, here is the concatenation of Hello and Udacity, notice
there's no space in between because there was no space in either this or that
string. If you wanted a space, you'd have to add a space. Strings are really
useful when you work with text. Sarah has a couple of nifty exercises prepared
for you when you get to work with a rather long text and take it apart. And put
pieces back together by using some of the string methods that you've seen here.
Enjoy.